voilà c'est ça qui est bon c'est le
début
[Rires]
[Musique]
je
la saint symphonie j'adore
[Applaudissements]
comme ça aussi
je me rappelle moi quand tu es arrivé tu
marchais comment je me rappelle ici
[Musique]
tu dis que des conneries
[Applaudissements]
une guerre crois-moi que je connais
des fois j'ai fait l'amour sur cette
chanson
que j'adore aussi non Roméo
[Musique]
pour y passer
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue
si vous trouvez avec cette fille
[Applaudissements]
on voudrait partir mais on reste ici
n'est pas la mauvaise voix ici de femmes
ils font la loi pas besoin de choisir
son camp on l'a fait pour toi et
longtemps vous êtes
la belle verte ici lorsque
vous
fleurit
c'est pas un paradis et nos adresses
sont dans la paix vous êtes
[Musique]
j'adore j'adore allez mec vous me faites
rêver
vous mettez la main j'adore
il était vénère de ouf le gars était
géniaux
merci les gars
attention
vous savez pas comment je suis comme un
fou de vous avoir et c'est des voix de
ouf hein
exactement
[Rires]
je la donne
dans les canapés
[Rires]
[Musique]
pour l'autre sens bien
sûr les étoiles ça te dérange pas
c'est notre amour qui n'aura jamais de
lendemain mon frère
bien plus qu'un monde qui s'ouvre
bien plus qu'elle voit
à la famille Daniel d'ailleurs et on
aime Daniel on aime Daniel
d'abord
à Paris samedi 22 avril et en tournée
dans toute la France ça va être un
énorme
[Applaudissements]